RAYMOND ARROYO HAS MORE ON THAT
IN FRIDAY FOLLIES.
FIRST, AFTER FIVE DAYS, A DOZEN
WITNESSES AND 30-PLUS HOURS OF
TESTIMONY, THE IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS ENDED UP A TOTAL BUST.
DESPITE PUBLIC OPINION TURNING
AGAINST THEM, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SO FAR OUT ON THE LEDGE, THAT I
THINK THEY FEEL AS IF THEY CAN'T
BACK AWAY FROM MOVING FORWARD.
NOW, THEY'RE LIKELY CONSIDERING
THE FOLLOWING ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
THE FIRST IS THE GENERIC ABUSE
OF POWER.
>> THE FOCUS REMAINS ON THE
PRESIDENT'S STUNNING ABUSE OF
POWER THAT RELATES TO HIS
PRESSURING A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
TO TARGET A CITIZEN FOR GAIN.
>> Laura: NONE OF THE WITNESSES
THAT THE DEMOCRATS PRODUCED
ACTUALLY HAD DIRECT EVIDENCE OF
ANYTHING APPROACHING STUNNING
LET ALONE AN ABUSE OF POWER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP NEVER TOLD ME
DIRECTLY THAT THE AID WAS
CONDITIONED ON THE MEETINGS.
>> THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T COME
AFTER THE BIDENS OR ANY
INVESTIGATIONS?
>> NO.
>> DID YOU EVER TALK TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2019?
>> NO, I HAVE NOT.
>> YOU WERE NOT ON THE CALL?
>> I WAS NOT ON THE CALL.
>> Laura: SECOND, DEMOCRATS
COULD CHARGE BRIBERY.
>> MY COLLEAGUES SEEM TO THINK
UNLESS THE PRESIDENT SAYS THE
MAGIC WORDS THAT I BRIBED THE
UKRAINIANS, THAT THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF BRIBERY.
>> THAT IS SOLICITING A BRIBE.
THAT IS AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> THE DEVASTATING TESTIMONY
CORROBORATED EVIDENCE OF
BRIBERY.
>> Laura: THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF
IT'S PATENTLY ABSURD.
EVEN CONGRESSMAN WILL HURD,
REPUBLICAN, WHO IS RETIRING --
HE'S NOT A HUGE FAN OF THE
PRESIDENT -- REJECTED THAT
ARGUMENT IN YESTERDAY'S HEARING.
>> AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE SHOULD
BE COMPELLING, OVERWHELMINGLY
CLEAR AND UNAMBIGUOUS.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING TO BE RUSHED
OR TAKEN LIGHTLY.
I HAVE NOT HEARD EVIDENCE
BRIEFING THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED
BRIBERY.
>> Laura: IT'S LAUGH IF IT
WASN'T SO BAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
THE THIRD POTENTIAL ARTICLE OF
IMPEACHMENT, CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
>> ARTICLE 3 IN THE NIXON
IMPEACHMENT ARTICLES, CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS.
DONALD TRUMP GOES WAY BEYOND
RICHARD NIXON.
>> Laura: IT'S HYPERBOLE.
WE'RE IN AN OLYMPIC EVENT, HE
WOULD BE DRAPED IN GOLD RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S CONTEMPT FOR CONGRESS, NOT
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS AT THIS
POINT.
TRUMP'S BEEN MORE FORTH COMING
TO CONGRESS THAN OBAMA.
OF COURSE, WHEN HE WAS UNDER THE
SPOTLIGHT, MORE PRESS EVENTS,
MADE HIMSELF MORE AVAILABLE,
SENT OUT MORE TWEETS.
RIDICULOUS.
FINALLY, DEMOCRATS COULD TRY TO
CHARGE TRUMP.
THIS PERHAPS IS MY FAVORITE OF
THE FAUX CHARGES, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> THEY KEEP TAKING IT TO COURT.
NO, WE'RE NOT GOING TO WAIT TILL
THE COURTS DECIDE.
WE CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT IT'S A
TECHNIQUE.
IT'S OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
>> Laura: THIS, AGAIN, IS
PERHAPS THE MOST PATHETIC CHARGE
OF ALL.
IT'S ANOTHER SIGN THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST OUT OF STEAM.
A PRESIDENT INVOKING A
TIME-HONORED PRIVILEGE LIKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HIS LEGAL RIGHT IS OBSTRUCTION
OF CONGRESS?
IF SO, THEN EVERYBODY OUT THERE,
YOU BETTER BUCKLE UP BECAUSE
POLITICS IS JUST GOING TO GET
UGLIER AND UGLIER AS TIME GOES
ON.
DEVIN NUNES PERHAPS SAID IT
BEST.
>> WHEN THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T GET
ANY TRACTION FOR ALLEGATIONS OF
QUID PRO QUO, THEY MOVE THE GOAL
POSTS AND ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT
OF EXTORTION.
THEN BRIBERY.
AT LEAST RESORT, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Laura: NONE OF THIS IS
WORKING.
DEEP DOWN SCHIFF, PELOSI AND
THEIR IMPEACHMENT BACKUP
SINGERS, THEY KNOW IT.
BUT IN ONE FINAL DESPERATE
EFFORT TO WIN OVER A WEARY
NATION, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE OH
SO BORED DID HIS BEST TO BELT
OUT A GRAND FINALE.
>> THEY WERE SILENT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
WHAT DO YOU WANT -- NO QUID PRO
QUO.
WE CAN'T JUST GET OVER IT.
WHERE IS HOWARD BAKER?
NOT USING METAPHORS.
I THINK WE NEED TO CONSULT OUR
CONSCIOUS.
I RESISTED GOING DOWN THIS PATH
A LONG TIME.
WE'RE BETTER THAN THAT.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE GAVEL AT
THE END.
MAKES IT REALLY PERSUASIVE
EXCEPT IT DOESN'T.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE A MAN THAT
IS CONFIDENT THAT HIS HEARING
DID THE JOB?
REALLY PERSUASIVE?
SEEM TO YOU LIKE IT WAS A
PERFORMER BEGGING THE AUDIENCE
FOR APPLAUSE?
JOINING ME NOW, ROBERT RAY,
FORMER WHITEWATER INDEPENDENT
CANCEL AND HARMET DILLON, DONALD
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISORY MEMBER.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS OF THE MIND
THAT THE HOUSE MIGHT NOT EVEN
VOTE ON IMPEACHMENT.
BUT I THINK THEY'RE PRETTY FAR
OUT THERE ON THAT LEDGE TO BACK
AWAY.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS GOING?
>> I DO, TOO, LAURA.
I THINK THEY'RE OUT ON THE
LEDGE.
THE ONLY EXIT RAMP WOULD BE
CONSIDER OF A POSSIBLE CENSURE
RESOLUTION.
THAT'S ONE THAT HAS OFTEN BEEN
DISCUSSED IN CONNECTION WITH
IMPEACHMENTS THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING, THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AN APPETITE
FOR THAT.
HERE THE DEMOCRATS ARE TOO FAR
OUT ON A LIMB APPEALING TO THE
INTERESTS OF THE PROGRESSIVE
WING OF THE PARTY.
I THINK SPEAKER PELOSI HAS
SIGNALS THAT SHE HAS TO GO DOWN
THIS ROAD FOR FEAR IF SHE
DOESN'T, SHE JEOPARDIZES HER
SPEAKERSHIP AFTER THE 2020
ELECTIONS.
>> Laura: HARMET, WHEN YOU HEAR
CHARGE AFTER CHARGE, THE GOAL
POSTS SHIFTING WHEN THEY WEREN'T
GETTING THE PUBLIC OPINION
POLLING THAT THEY WANTED, THEY
FOCUSED GROUPED IT AT ONE POINT
IN THE DCC, DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEE, THEY WERE FOCUS
GROUPED DETERMINING WHAT THE
PROPER ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT
SHOULD BE.
SO IS THERE ANY SURPRISE THAT
ADAM SCHIFF IS DESPERATELY
TRYING TO CONJURE UP THIS
EMOTION TO CLOSE IT OUT
YESTERDAY?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED.
THERE'S NO FACTS TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT.
YOU THINK HE WOULD HAVE LEARNED
FROM JERRY NADLER'S BELLY FLOP
IN THE MUELLER INVESTIGATIONS
AND HEARINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
PREPARED AND MAKE SURE WITNESSES
CAN DELIVER.
HIS WITNESSES WENT AFTER WRITING
CHECKS, THAT DID NOT DELIVER ON
THE IMPEACHMENT PROMISE.
SO IF I'M NANCY PELOSI TONIGHT,
I'M FEELING WORRIED ABOUT MY
PROSPECTS BECAUSE SHE HAS
PAINTED HERSELF IN A CORNER.
SHE HAS TO DO SOMETHING OR SHE
WILL LOSE HER POSITION AND THE
PARTY WILL LOSE AT THE POLLS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A DUD AND DEAD
ON ARRIVAL IN THE SENATE.
>> Laura: ROBERT, I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THAT ISSUE OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
AGAIN, THEY'RE FRANTIC IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO TIE THIS BACK TO
NIXON.
PEOPLE THINK OH, IF IT'S LIKE
NIXON, IT HAS TO BE BAD AND HE
WILL RESIGN AND WE'LL BE HAPPY.
OH, IT'S OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HE WOULD INVOKE AN EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE TO NOT APPEAR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE.
HOW DANGEROUS A PRECEDENT WOULD
THAT SET MOVING FORWARD, ROBERT?
>> IT'S HORRIBLE.
THIS IS AN INTRABRANCH DISPUTE.
SINCE WHEN IS FILING A LAWSUIT
EVER BE CONSIDERED AN ACT OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE?
THAT IS A RIDICULOUS NOTION.
THAT'S AN APPEAL TO THE -- TO
ANOTHER BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, A
COURT, TO MAKE A DETERMINATION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT A PRIVILEGE
APPLIES.
YOU CAN ARGUE ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT, BUT THE CONTENTION THAT
MERELY BY FILING A LAWSUIT THAT
THAT IS OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
IS A RIDICULOUS NOTION.
>> Laura: NANCY PELOSI MADE IT
CLEAR THAT SHE'S NOT GOING TO
COURT.
OH, WE DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THAT.
IF IT'S SUCH A CRITICAL ISSUE
FOR THE COUNTRY TO WRESTLE WITH,
FOR CONGRESS TO WRESTLE WITH,
SHE WOULD GO TO COURT BECAUSE
SHE WOULD BE CONFIDENT SHE WOULD
WIN AND WANT THE LEGAL
PRECEDENT, WOULD SHE NOT,
HARMEET?
>> THE COURT SYSTEM IS PART OF
OUR GOVERNMENT AND PART OF THE
DUE PROCESS SYSTEM.
SO I THINK SHE'S JUST WHISTLING
PAST THE GRAVEYARD, LAURA.
SHE KNOWS SHE DOESN'T HAVE THE
GOODS.
THEY WOULD KICK HER OUT.
THERE'S NOT THE EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE.
LAURA, THIS IS A POLITICAL
PROCESS.
THAT'S HOW THE FOUNDERS MADE IT.
ALL OF THESE DEMOCRATS NEED TO
BE THINKING A COUPLE STEPS AHEAD
TO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE VOTERS,
CLEARLY BORED, TURNED OFF OR
OTHERWISE, YOU KNOW, REVOLTED AT
THIS PROSPECT OF THESE DEMOCRATS
SPENDING THEIR TIME ON THIS AND
NOT ON THE PEOPLE'S WORK.
WHO WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
IT'S NOT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: ROBERT, REPUBLICANS
NOW SAY, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
SAYING TO THE COUNSEL'S OFFICE
AND VARIOUS REPORTS THAT THEY
WANT A SENATE TRIAL.
>> THESE PROCEEDINGS HAVE BEEN
ANYTHING BUT FAIR.
THE SENATE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FIX THAT.
I'M CONFIDENT THEY WILL.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THEM
COMPLETING THE JOB THAT WE COULD
HAVE DONE HERE.
>> Laura: NOW APPARENTLY THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING I WANT A
TRIAL.
BUT ROBERT, IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT THE GOP ITSELF SHOULD WANT?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
LOOK, I THINK THAT THE TRIAL IN
THE SENATE IS MOSTLY ABOUT A
DELIBERATION OVER WHETHER OR NOT
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE.
THE EVIDENCE IS ALREADY IN.
I COULD FORESEE LINDSEY GRAHAM
THROUGH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SUBPOENAING HUNTER BIDEN AND
GETTING DEPOSITION TESTIMONY.
BUT RECALL THE CLINTON
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE WASN'T LIVE TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
THERE WERE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
DEPOSITIONS.
THE EVIDENCE WAS SHARED WITH THE
SENATORS.
MOSTLY AN IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING
BEFORE THE SENATE IS A TRIAL
PROCEEDING, A DELIBERATION.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD PRESENT A
CASE IN THE SENSE THAT THERE
WOULD BE STATEMENTS AS WOULD THE
IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS THAT WOULD
ACT ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSE.
BUT LIVE TESTIMONY IS NOT WHAT I
IMAGINE THAT WE WOULD SEE BEFORE
THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
I THINK FINALLY, AFTER A COUPLE
OF WEEKS OF THIS SINCE THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE CONTROL OF THE
CHAMBER, I WOULD IMAGINE A
MOTION TO DISMISS WOULD BE
PROPERLY FILED AND CONSIDERED.
WE WOULD END THIS IN SHORT
CIRCUIT IT WITHOUT THE PRESIDENT
EVEN HAVING TO PUT ON A DEFENSE.
>> Laura: HARMEET, TALKING ABOUT
LINDSEY GRAHAM OPENING THIS
PROBE, A PROBE INTO BIDEN
BURISMA.
HE'S DEMANDING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT TURN OVER THE
COMMUNICATIONS AMONG FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HUNTER BIDEN
AND THE UKRAINE.
THIS IS ALL IN RESPONSE TO THESE
ALLEGATIONS THAT BIDEN PUSHED TO
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR GENERAL,
MR. SHOKIN JUST TO END THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE COMPANY
THAT EMPLOYED HIS SON THAT PAID
HIM $80,000 A MONTH.
HERE'S HOW BIDEN REACTED TO
THIS.
>> I'M DISAPPOINTED AND QUITE
FRANKLY ANGERED BY THE FACT.
HE KNOWS MY SON.
HE KNOWS THERE'S NOTHING TO
THIS.
TRUMP IS NOW ESSENTIALLY HOLDING
POWER OVER HIM THAT EVEN
UKRAINIANS WOULDN'T YIELD TO.
LINDSAY IS ABOUT TO GO DOWN A
WAY THAT HE WILL REGRET HIS
LIFE.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> I'M EMBARRASSED BY WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
>> Laura: HARMEET, JOE BIDEN
THAT TALKED ABOUT PUNCHING SAID
HE'S EMBARRASSED FOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL STAND UP
TO THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE FEELS
APPROPRIATE.
YOU CAN SEE THE SOAP OPERA
PLAYING OUT TO KNOW THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING FISHY ABOUT THAT GUY
GETTING $80,000 A MONTH FOR
ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW, BIDEN IS -- I DON'T
THINK HE'S THINKING CLEARLY
ABOUT HOW THIS LOOKS FROM AFAR.
THAT BRINGS ME BACK TO THE
SENATE.
THESE SENATORS HAVE A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST, A LOT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS WILL BE
GRANDSTANDING FOR THE CAMERAS
AND HAVING NOTHING TO DO IF THIS
IS --
>> Laura: HOLD ON, HARMEET.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POINT.
ISN'T IT TRUE THAT THE SENATORS
CAN NOT SPEAK AT THE TRIAL?
THEY DON'T SPEAK.
THEY SIT THERE LIKE POTTED
PLANTS.
>> IN THE TRIAL.
NOT OUTSIDE.
>> Laura: YEAH, YEAH.
>> IT'S ALL GOING TO BE MUGGING
FOR THE CAMERAS -- YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Laura: BUT ROBERT, DURING THE
PROCEEDING THEY DON'T SAY
ANYTHING.
>> LARGELY THIS IS A
DELIBERATIVE PROCEEDING TO
ARRIVE AT A VERDICT ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE.
>> Laura: PREPOSTEROUS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE THE
VOTE.
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> Laura: THEY THINK IT'S GOOD